hey everybody Neil deGrasse Tyson here
we recently posted a short 10 minute
maybe explainer video on what nuclear
fusion is and why it matters for the
future of energy and it basically went
viral went viral for us I had a couple
of million views and a relatively short
amount of time and we read the comments
and people said give us more we want to
learn more about this than what I could
possibly squeeze into 10 minutes so we
heeded your advice we do read the
comments and we've put together an
entire show on that very subject and who
do we get for it the operations manager
at the national ignitions facility of
Lawrence Livermore National Labs he's a
physicist and his name is Bruno van Von
and we have an entire show with him as
our guest telling us about what they
achieved how they achieved it and what
it means for the future of civilization
so I present to you the show that all of
you called for on Star Talk
[Music]
this is Star Talk
today we're going to talk about fusion
and lasers
ooh Coast Chuck Nice how you doing man
hey Neil how are you yeah fusion and
Laser's been in all the news who would
have thought it is the hottest thing
going okay oh I see what you did there
God I'm so sorry
and we did a little explainer video and
I I got people comfortable with what was
going on at the Lawrence Livermore Labs
yeah uh but we thought why don't we just
get why don't we just get somebody from
the labs I mean okay why not that sounds
good so allow me to introduce you and
our audience to our special guest uh Dr
Bruno Von well to him
from the national ignition facility at
the Lawrence Livermore National Labs
Bruno welcome to StarTalk all right my
pleasure okay excellent excellent and
you know you definitely are you have to
be Dutch but are you feeling it okay you
know what yeah that was such a Dutch
answer like you know what I mean all
right okay
that's how we react to it that's how you
do it I'm serious yeah yeah and so right
now you are um am I think director of
the national ignition facility and uh
him also operations manager for the
facility so I basically keep my uh pills
on everything that is happening in the
facility and make sure that the
experiments are done well and done
effectively and safely and make sure
that we get the great results going in
America in America we call that boss man
yeah
that's how everyone thinks about me
and the man that's in there in charge
yeah I got my hand on everything
so yeah in your past you have a PhD in
chemical physics from the University of
Louisville in Belgium is that correct
yes excellent excellent and uh your
background isn't basically lasers which
is so cool it's always been about lasers
and as I started out I mean I was
working with some of course much smaller
laser so but I got my eyes on what was
going on in the world in other
Laboratories and
so in the
1980s I moved over for a postdoc at the
University of California in Irvine again
working on lasers and x-ray sources and
very interesting projects
with respect to laser physics
then I moved to work for a couple of
years at the Max Planck Institute in
gertingen in Germany and just remind me
the Max Planck Institute is many
different centers that each have an
emphasis correct because we have one in
astrophysics but that's not the same one
you're describing correct that's the
music so I was working in the the one of
us uh focusing on biophysical chemistry
and using lasers I mean to uh develop
all kinds of diagnostic techniques and
actually it evolved into a laser
production Center it was studying I mean
extremely high powered eczema lasers the
different type of technology that again
it was I mean the biggest eczema or the
highest power XML laser under
development in the world at that point
in time when that's how I met a visiting
scientists from Livermore explaining
about Fusion technology explaining about
the uh Nova laser that was in operation
at that time at Livermore and basically
putting a a picture of a Nova laser beam
on the Whiteboard which was about I mean
yeah big
and that convinced me really they just
say well that's the place that's where I
belong so um like I said we posted a
short 10 minute sort of update after the
news hit and in the comments thread of
our just little 10-minute update there's
a bunch of questions we want to sort of
bring into this much more full and
fleshed out program and so uh we just
there's an unlimited number of these
questions we we called them and so I
could you just tell us
first of all the national ignition
facility when we think of ignition we
think of turning on our car so what is
you when you say ignition what do you
mean
I think plasma is basically a plasma
that
Heats itself up higher and higher and so
the heat that is generated is larger
than the energy losses I mean you lose
energy from a reaction I mean through
radiation through conduction of energy
away from the plasma a bit if you can
generate so much heat that you overcome
those losses then you keep heating up
you keep accelerating the fusion
reactions and basically it becomes a
runaway reaction and it's uh like a
match that you light up when you start
slow and suddenly it flares up and it
burns up immediately
and so an igniting plasma is a plasma
that sustains itself and heats itself up
higher and higher so you get more Fusion
you get more ignition you get more heat
production and basically whoosh you
basically burn all the fuel that you
have collected and compressed around
that little hot spot that ignites the
plasma so we call that hot spot ignition
I'd like your reference to the Striking
of a match uh because of course when you
start out with a match and a little you
know a rough surface uh there is no heat
anywhere right and so then you strike it
and then you start something and it
doesn't need you to keep helping it it
just is self-sustained as it continues
yes it takes up by itself
and it goes faster and faster and it
actually is over and just I mean a tenth
of a billionth of a second and that's
the amazing thing is you create this
enormous amount of energy through the
fusion process and it is basically
released in I mean from a tiny little
spots in an incredibly short amount of
time so the amount of power that is
generated is just incredible and I mean
it shows I mean the power of fusion
really wait wait but I from the from the
notes I saw
you invested is it 300 million joules of
energy
that that seems like a high starting
point it's a lot of blame that's a lot
of bling
it's a it's a lot of energy but uh what
we're comparing or the official
definition of Target gain is comparing
the energy we put into the target to the
energy that came out of the target
um right and so even if 300 million is a
big number yeah 300 million Jewelers is
a lot of energy but we also have to keep
in mind that the national ignition
facility was never built for efficiency
it was built for for cost Effectiveness
and so we choose I mean the most
inexpensive power supplies the most
reliable laser systems and it worked it
was cost effective but it wasn't I mean
built for efficiency and could have
built the system with an efficiency that
is 10 to 50 percent or 10 to 50 times
higher
uh if we would like I mean to do that so
so yes I mean it is a big number but
it's no surprise and
uh okay so look at it over time
what you're saying is you you put in 300
million jewels you got out more than 300
million jewels but not much more and
what you're telling me if I understand
is this was a test of concept now that
it works you could go back in and say
let's make this laser a little more
efficient and this so so you can ignite
it in principle with fewer than 300
million jewels in a new design in the
future
yes so so let's repeat that so we had
again we had 300 Mega shoes of
electrical energy that's converted to 3
million joules of laser energy
which is then oh sorry two million
joules of laser energy which was
incident on the Target and compressor
Target and then the target itself
emitted three million joules again so we
had a in the from that point of view a
one percent return but a 50 relative to
the laser energy that was used to I mean
push the fuel capsule together and
ignite it wait wait wait wait so wait so
you you needed energy to power the
lasers yes okay but you're not counting
that in your in the return on the
investment though you're only comparing
your laser energy to what came out of
your pellet but the fact that you have
to plug all this into the wall yeah of
course is it fair and effective it that
way then
it is fair but uh
once you start to think about now how
can we I mean turn this into a process
that the delivers energy
and can create or use the fusion process
I mean to to drive a power plant then of
course that efficiency of the driver
becomes very important I mean you need
to start working on higher gain targets
you need to start working on higher
efficiency laser drivers and I think
these two in combination I mean can
basically deliver to amid feasible
inertial Fusion Energy plant okay so
it's engineering at that point you can
hand it over the engineers and say make
this work so can I can I can I ask you
this so you said that it's like striking
a match and that is self-sustaining is
there a process where we don't have to
worry about how much energy it took to
start it because it is self-perpetuating
afterwards good question
there you go you solved it okay now go
home
actually uh the inertial confinement
Fusion which is the process that we're
using uh takes a finite amount of fuel
in a little Target and compresses it
and then creates Fusion in the center to
light off the little fuel match around
it
but it's a finite amount of fuel and so
once that fuel is burned we need to
start that process over again so we
bring in a new Target we again hit it
with the laser compress it create the
hot spot that ignites it have the
ignition burn up the fuel and do it over
and over and over again and
uh so we believe that for a neutral
Fusion Energy plant you need to do that
about 10 times per second right instead
of once a day
and so it's a process that you repeat
over and over again so it it's not that
we have a gigantic amount of fuel that
we can compress it's a small amount but
it also makes it inherently safe there
is no runaway condition there's nothing
I mean that basically can melt down or
become unsafe from that point of view
the best thing that can happen is that
all the fuel burns up and that's it
right so I'm unlike that that's current
unlike our current nuclear power plants
where you know the the actual uh Chain
Reaction can run away and we can't stop
it
yes you can have meltdown conditions you
can have all kinds of uh undesirable
effects and very unsafe conditions that
can be created but that is not the case
for inertial Fusion Energy so before we
go to our first break could you explain
why
you need such high temperatures in like
the tens or even did I read 100 million
degrees what is the temperature doing
for you so the temperature is needed
actually to overcome the repulsive
forces that normally prevent uh the
nuclei in atoms from basically uh
basically combining with each other
there's no positive charge yeah they're
all positive charges so the closer you
bring them they start to repel each
other vehemently which is a good thing
because otherwise the whole world would
collapse immediately so
Jason
so there's an incredible force that
prevents you from molecules from abusing
and in order to actually then
overcome those forces and then have
denuclear Force which is the force that
actually pulls the charges together in a
in a Decor of an atom
uh you need to have incredible
temperatures in order to start uh
creating I mean violence I mean
collisions between the atoms so
you can relate the temperatures to
kinetic energy of the atoms moving
around and if you want to increase that
temperature increase the velocity at
which they collide with each other you
need to go to temperatures of about 150
million degrees in order for deuterium
and tritium basically to fuse together
and for some other systems I mean it can
go up to billions of degrees before you
can actually reach conditions
where the the nuclei can overcome I mean
the forces that normally uh hold prevent
them from collapsing so presumably this
has been some of the decades-long
challenge that this process has
encountered uh yeah
okay and from the initial idea that the
lab I mean developed soon after the
invention of the laser in 1960s
yeah it has taken us about 60 years
basically to learn how to do this and
learn how to achieve ignition and and
that's why the December experiment was
such a spectacular event because it
basically I mean shows us that whatever
was deemed impossible for so many years
by so many people was basically overcome
using just a continuous development of
technological and scientific
developments in the laboratory
where we I mean develop new codes new
computers new and bigger laser systems
over 60 years to finally come up with a
laser and a Target design that actually
did the tree can work and you know
you're talking about rooms full of smart
people just say it
I mean it is a campus full of smart
people smart people because even one
campus is multiple campuses across the
country yeah across the world that I've
participated in this of course Bruno in
the center of the Sun
um
it's actually not hot enough
to fuse the hydrogen outright and when
we run the calculations because the
center of the sun is like 10 million
degrees around there that it's mostly
driven through tunneling
Quantum tunneling of the protons to come
together and so you can get the
tunneling at the lower temperature are
you saying that your process going up to
100 million degrees The Brute Force
slamming together of the protons that
you're not taking advantage of any
quantum mechanical tunneling that might
be available to you
there is some amount of tunneling
involved but I think we want to
basically I mean speed up the process
and uh that's where we try to reach the
highest temperatures because if you look
at the fusion energy production in the
sun it's actually really small it's on
the old of a few hundreds what's per
cubic meters which is I mean almost like
the level of a compost pile
so the enormous amount of energy from
the Sun really comes from the gigantic
just happens
damn that's I've never heard anyone have
shade on the sun before yeah you just
did you did you put you you threw shade
at the sun it's just like you're not so
hot oh you're not so you're about as hot
as a you know a pile of garbage under
some dirt sun when I was steaming manure
yeah there you go
and it's a good thing actually because
if it if the sun was igniting I mean
that would be that wouldn't be a good
day for us so yeah of course nice and
study process all right got it right
whereas when you yeah when you go to the
full up temperature that physically gets
the protons together without relying on
the tunneling which is a kind of an
effect happening in the edges of the of
the process if you go full up then
you're gonna get the full Hammer of your
Fusion okay what great like villain
story for a Bond movie like because Bond
movies love lasers right yeah they do
yeah so it's like a an evil genius who
comes up with a laser that he's going to
use to ignite the plasma of the Sun and
destroy the whole solar system forget
the one where he's just like I'm going
to destroy a city he's like I'm gonna
wipe out the whole solar system okay
that's why I don't have a job at
Lawrence Livermore Labs job
all right we're gonna take a break when
we come back we're gonna get into lasers
and what are they and how do they work
and why are they useful for this and I
want to get into a little bit of dare I
say the chemistry of what's going on in
the nuclear reactions like what are the
nuclei that are actually coming together
and where do you start and where do you
end so we'll get into that when we
return on this edition of StarTalk we're
talking about lasers and fusion we'll be
right back
we're back start talks we're talking
about lasers and fusion and of course
the person powering this conversation is
Bruno then Balto him who is the acting
director of the national ignition
facility at Lawrence Livermore National
Labs at Bruno so before we get on to
just what lasers are and how they work
and why uh just remind me how what what
particles are you putting together in
what sequence before you declare that
you have completed your Fusion paths so
the fusion reaction that we are pursuing
is deuterium and territium being fused
together to form a helium atom and a
neuteron so the neuteron runs away with
a good fraction of the energy of the
fusion reaction while the helium is a
massive particle that is actually used
to heat up the remaining Fusion fuel all
and in the process of fusion
we convert mass into energy and based
upon Einstein's equation E equals m c
squared
c squared being gigantic number a little
bit of mass is actually converted into a
lot of energy and you create a more I
mean stable a little bit less mass and a
lot of energy and that is what we're
trying to harvest in this process wait
wait so how about the runaway a neutron
where does that go into witness
protection witness protection
it just goes and scatters around in
concrete until it basically finally
stops but it can be harvested using the
correct or the appropriate technology
and turned into useful energy or turned
into electricity or something that
that's what I was wondering because you
can't electrically trap it because it's
neutral so it actually so all this
energy has to just sort of slam into
something and then and that energy then
becomes heat I guess correct yes so yeah
there there's a collector what would it
be I'm so fascinated by this right now I
don't know what to do my head is
swimming so you know the byproduct the
neutron so here it is scattering are you
saying that you could some sort of
collector and what and you would be able
to gather that
yes it's something like a molten salt
mantle around the target chamber that
kinetically absorb the neutrons and get
heat to them
Jesus Christ you could heat that could
heat up and that could be you to
actually do the the traditional way we
make energy right now which is heat
water turned into the Steam and turn the
turbine except that you're not burning
anything to to create that steam that is
do you know that the oil companies are
going to kill you man
what are you doing
they like it you should not be in public
all right all right I'm sorry we'll
embargo this this workout right so but
let me get back to this I know that you
can find deuterium in just regular water
supply it was one out of whatever a
thousand Watermark tools has a whatever
the number maybe one out of 100 I think
has of the hydrogen in the H2O is
actually deuterium where are you getting
your hydrogen that has two neutrons
which is the tritium sorry sorry I'm
sorry your two physicists talking to
each other regular person here okay
let's you let's get back rewind I got
this i got this I got it okay so
hydrogen minding its own business yes
one proton right that's normal hydrogen
right you can give it a neutron it's
still hydrogen that's right except it's
a little heavier when we call it heavy
hydrogen okay
deuterium so that's two okay okay you
can get it
second Neutron cramming in there now it
has three nuclear particles and that's
tritium okay but it's still hydrogen
it's still hydrogen okay so now that's
what's going on here that's what's going
on so now the other thing is one in
every what molecules now is uh tell me
Bruno is it 100 or one in a thousand
somewhere around there
uh one in five thousand uh atoms in
normal like uh or seawater is actually
a heavy uh hydrogen or a deuterium atom
so it can be extracted I mean through
chemical techniques through distillation
and plus it's combining it's making the
same molecule as a regular H2O because
it's right chemistry is the same it's
just a heavier hydrogen right man I'm
telling you right now if I had just
known all this crap when I was in school
I might not be a comedian right now
amazing no it's fun it's fun stuff
so Bruno where are you getting
now the territory is a much more
complicated story because it doesn't
occur in a natural process except that
at extremely lower balances like 10
minus 18 which is physically
non-existent
so our current
supply of tritium release generated as a
byproduct in traditional nuclear
reactors
for example one way that it's generated
is by you take a deuterium atom and you
bombard it with neutrons like what
happens in a nuclear reactor if it heavy
water is used to cool then it creates
once in a while at a tritium atom and
you can extract that and make it
available for use technically then it
takes energy to make the the tritium
that's in your reaction is that part of
your energy budget so that's the current
process uh the process that we would
like to pursue for inertial Fusion
Energy is to use a much use the neutrons
that are generated in the fusion process
to create your own territum and you can
do that for example by
bombarding lithium or molten lithium or
lithium salt with neutrons and that
creates tritium that can then be
extracted from the process so you once
you have enough fuel to start you can
start creating I mean you your own fuel
right so once again self-perpetual
you're eating the whole carcass there's
nothing left over using it all yes
yes
okay so now you get to your so you do
that they come together in your high
temperature now you have
helium three
right so now we have two protons which
is helium and normally it wants two
neutrons but now it only has one Neutron
so that's helium three and you're still
not done correct yeah okay I guess what
I'm asking is I happen to know you
surely know also that uh the solar wind
is very rich in helium-3 and helium
three is heavily embedded in the surface
of the Moon and there's been talk of
mining surface mining the helium-3 from
the Moon and then injecting that
directly into your nuclear fusion so you
don't have to go through the the the the
the deuterium trading process before you
land on helium-4 the full uh red blooded
helium so what any thoughts about that
uh yeah there is an alternative fusion
reaction the D plus helium-3 can easily
also form helium 4. uh and but it's
threshold of the temperature that is
needed in order to start a reaction is
is higher almost twice as high as the
theory matritium and not as effective so
we still have a more efficient process
with DT than the D helium tree did not
know that okay all right yeah so the the
deuterium tritium I mean fusion reaction
is really the most effective way of
achieving I mean ignition and operating
the system although many others are
pursued I mean they are much less
efficient and much harder to achieve so
you're saying you don't actually make
helium 4 you you stop at the helium-3
and you get enough energy and you're
happy with that
yeah okay now let me pivot now to lasers
because all this is in enabled empowered
by lasers and this is your bailiwick
here so so let's let's get on the same
page here what's the difference between
my PowerPoint laser
at 192 lasers you blasted your target
with the amount of power generated by a
typical uh pointing source is about a
few milliwatts the nif can generate 500
trillion Watts 500 petawatts on a Target
and with an energy of uh two megajoules
two million jewels yeah so yeah which is
I mean billions and billions times more
than what's typically obtained from a
small laser so it is the world's largest
highest energy and highest powered laser
uh it's uh contains 192 individual laser
beams each of these laser beams can go
up to I mean uh 10 or a little bit more
than 10 kilojoules of UV radiation
which is uh each by itself I mean the
world's largest laser
and so it is a tremendous
uh departure from the typical and the
previously used lasers in Fusion
ignition it's almost a factor of 60
larger than the Nova laser and similar
than others or the similar factors
compared to other lasers in the world
and so it is one of the first lasers
that is really engineered instead of
being a tabletop large scientific laser
it's a laser that is really designed to
be compact cost effective
I mean high energy high power and it is
really set up I mean to meet ignition
and rear worked uh almost 20 years to
bring that laser from initial design in
the early 90s
to starting the building at the end of
the night is starting the laser begin
beginning of the 2000s and completing
the lasers in 2009 when we started to do
actual experiments so it took us 20
years I mean to build and put these
lasers together
and it it wasn't incredible I mean it's
it's a laser that was just engineered so
well that when we brought it up it all
worked and it all met it actually it's a
design requirements that very quickly it
exceeded its design requirements in the
way that we currently operated and the
way that we achieved the ignition
experiment just to be clear did I hear
you say that each of the 192 lasers is
itself the most powerful laser in the
world did you say wow yes so this is the
laser that cats actually hate
you can't say no yeah they don't just
like look at that we lost another cat
guys
yeah no yeah they have no recourse
against it
[Laughter]
so so but just to be clear my low power
presentation laser which you dissed
um I presume makes a laser beam in in
the same using the same physics as your
lasers isn't that great that's correct
so tell us what that physics is
so the the physics is based upon uh
light amplification by stimulated
emission of radiation
forward I mean to describe I mean the
process by which you can actually store
energy in molecules and use radiation to
actually
stimulate or trigger the emission of
photons
so that when you do that in a coherent
way in a way where a beam of photons
that goes in the same direction with the
same wavelength uh basically creates
more photons or more copies of itself
and creates a brighter and brighter beam
that goes One Direction that has one
color and that is the difference I mean
between a normal ordinary incandescent
bulb where you have light it goes all
directions over a wide spectrum of
wavelengths the laser beams are now it's
a way of means of extracting energy from
a medium that you have excited
using another energy source and that
could be another laser there could be a
flash lamp
to provide a medium that then can
undergo
light amplification by the stimulated
emission of radiation and that's the
mechanism that is being used to generate
the laser beams so as you said
and the design of Any Given laser only
can generate one wavelength of light
that comes out so there's no you can't
tune a laser I guess it's only good for
that one
kind of light that comes out is that
correct
that's correct though some laser some
gain Media or methods I mean allow some
a little bit of tunability around the a
certain wavelength but the laser itself
is always I mean it's it's basically
characterized by its coherence and
that's it basically means a narrow
spectrum and a narrow spatial
distribution of the energies all right
so so the lasers we're all familiar with
use visible light the red lasers and
Green Lasers and now we have some blue
lasers but I heard you refer to
ultraviolet uh so are these UV lasers
instead
uh the laser itself the solid state
lasers that are used uh to add to create
the beams and amplify the beams largely
use neodymium in a glass media because
we need to be able to handle very high
energies and be very efficient at the
same time and they tend to operate in
the infrared so basically it's a
wavelength just above the visible region
uh it's just the wavelength around one
micron
now the targets don't like the infrared
light because they basically create a
plasma and stand the laser beam right
back towards the laser
which is not a good thing to happen and
so we learned in our previous laser
systems that you need to have a shorter
wavelength and we first started to
double the frequency of the laser so we
turn the infrared to Green
and finally we found that actually
converting the latest infrared to
ultraviolet was even much more efficient
because the ultraviolet light can
penetrate deeper into the plasma that
you're forming and so it's much better
much more of the energy is absorbed and
used for uh heating the plasma that then
can start your Fusion reactions yeah you
guys are being very efficient about
everything just move you know and and
I'm just trying to add up all the smarts
that that takes and I'm just very
impressed just listening to you talk
about this and you're in your in your
laser Dome that you have there these are
dumb
I like it we're going to take a quick
break when we come back we're going to
talk to our special guest this acting
director of the national ignition
facility of the Lawrence Livermore
National Labs we're going to ask him
about the future of lasers and and
what's next in line and and when are we
going to have Mr home Fusion to power
our cars like in the movie Back to the
Future we're gonna learn all of that
when we return on StarTalk
we're back start talk we're talking
about lasers and fusion with the acting
director of the national ignition
facility at the Lawrence Livermore
National Lab
I think I nailed that one that time yes
okay you get you get it so Bruno I've
heard people joke about Lawrence
Livermore Labs that those Three L's
really stand for lasers lasers and
lasers is that
so I I remember you know looking at the
Guinness Book of World Records tracking
who had the most powerful laser in the
world and it always landed at Livermore
so what why yes you did something great
with these most powerful lasers but over
time
why the why the the
is it just bragging rights that you have
the most powerful laser or is there some
real scientific objective for it it was
a scientific
and Technology bootstrapping process
where every time
we come up with the design for and
igniting Target or an igniting
experiment we build the lasers we try to
Target and we figured out well there was
something missing your understanding we
needed more laser energy and power there
were more energy losses in the process
there were different conditions and so
it took us five six of those Cycles
since the 70s to figure out the design
like the national ignition facility were
with high confidence he said we now have
the right recipe the right number of
lasers the right symmetry the right
Precision in the laser to achieve all
the conditions that are required to make
ignition happen
and it's not all about the size of the
lasers to equally important is just the
quality the accuracy and the Precision
of where you point the beams where you
time the beams how the power is
distributed because uh you take a
capsule and you compress it 30 fold so
you take a basketball and you turn it
into a p
and if you don't have I mean Exquisite
symmetry I mean you don't get a peak you
get some something that just I mean
comes out through your head that's the
sounds the sound effects as well yes yes
very good so you need extremely I mean
high energy high power but also
extremely precise uh it's extremely
stable extremely well controlled lasers
you're creating a perfect implosion
right yes from all directions out of
this sphere the only value of your
lasers is to get the right temperature
plasma when you're done we've also heard
of a magnetically contained infusion I
guess the Tokamak is a whole other
possible approach to Fusion how do they
get their plasma because their plasma is
also millions of degrees right
yeah but the plasma are lowers
temperature and densities and they are
basically held together using magnet
magnets in a large vacuum chamber so
it's a very large plasma that is uh
contained and heated up using uh an
induction process so it's quite
different so it's they don't use lasers
and
lasers are only used for Diagnostics
but not to derive the process
so and forgive me for some of our our
viewers and and listeners could you just
tell us what a plasma is because I think
we were just using it like it's of
course we know what a plasma is
typically most people's understanding of
the word comes from blood plasma right
to remove the I gives it the platelets
or whatever and what's left is plasma so
this medical plasma so what is the
physical plasma astrophysical plant
physical plasma is basically a
collection of a medium of atoms that has
been energized or to such a level that
it starts to lose its electrons and so
the electrons and the nuclei start to
form a Continuum and start to uh float
around each other
so you have free electrons so that means
that means it could respond to magnetic
fields whereas a normal gas would not
have the reason to yeah
okay and and and why why did they think
this was a good idea for televisions
class for televisions yeah it's it
but now you have lasers television too
this is true which is awesome yeah which
is sharper sharper than the yeah wait
isn't isn't the gas inside of neon tubes
a plasma and in fluorescent tubes isn't
that all plants because it's very easily
ionized and so it's it usually forms a
plasma without having to go to very high
temperatures it's just right and that
and that little you don't see it anymore
but that that glow ball yeah that's put
your hands on you put your hand on and
you see it's just like glowing gas Bruno
have you seen these I don't know how
they let you out you know
so we have seen those we use those
balls you know in gift shops yeah yeah
but they're all applications of it but
the the plasma also allows to uh to be
heated further and further and so you
can create I mean interesting conditions
and you can start to experiment and have
uh have atoms I mean do interesting I
mean physics for you and most of the
universe is plasma I mean all stars are
plasma and so we're we're kind of we
live with it when we study that I just
want to ask because you know as you were
talking about the refinement of these
lasers over a period of time but it's
always been in service to finding a
better way to achieve Fusion
in that process has there been
advancements in lasers that we benefit
like maybe you guys didn't benefit but
we did you mean spin-offs on roof
spin-offs yeah yeah
we have had a number of uh spin-offs
that are not uh directly I mean coming
to your home although I mean there were
a technique that is being used for
example to harden turbine blades
for jet engines using lasers that's
important now that has been
commercialized and is used on a
relatively wide scale
uh there are applications of
diagnostic systems that were developed
for laser Fusion facilities I just
wondered how the turbine blames are
harder maybe they'll just slice up those
ducts
well and then we can collect them on the
back end and make lunch so now when a
plane flies into flocks of geese or
whatever like uh Sully did in landing
but some River
um I don't know it helps it helps with
that but it also makes you feel better
when you're flying that you know the
engine is going to survive the flight
and not basically start to disassemble
somewhere on Route so when that happens
yeah ladies and gentlemen this is your
captain as you can see we just threw uh
flew through a flock of geese and I want
to let you know that our in-flight meal
today will be duck all around
[Laughter]
so Bruno tell me again do you think what
you have achieved here is scalable
whatever that word means as I'm using it
I don't know but scalable so that it can
be ported to power stations or maybe I
can have one of these in my garage or or
but yeah where does this go after what
you've done
yeah so this concept can lead to uh uh
the design of inertial Fusion Energy
based power plants
uh those are fairly large plants because
the laser system we're needing is is
it's not a small laser system it is a
large facility I mean we stuck in
stadiums sized lasers
we have to do a significant amount of
engineering development because we need
to run them at 10 times per second
instead of one time a day we need to
have targets that can be I mean produced
I mean at the rate of 10 times per
second
we need to develop I mean a system I
mean to capture the energy uh
hmm
produce the tritium fuel that is needed
to run it and then convert the energy I
mean basically to electricity but it's
just that's just engineering at this
point it's not physics there's a lot of
engineering there is no you got the
physics down if you get the physics done
I mean we still want more higher gain
than what we achieved on the December
experiment but we have ways to do that
we understand how we can achieve that
and so yes we believe that I mean within
a few a decade two decades we may have I
mean a working model of an inertial
Fusion Energy plant
and so how about one for my car where I
have a Mr Fusion home device you just
put stuff in the top and then close it
down and then I run that's my day's fuel
is that would be like a portable version
of it right
so that is a little bit I mean uh
further or far-fetched from this because
I mean right now the scale of the lasers
or the scale up that is required I mean
doesn't lend itself easily I mean to a
very a compact system so but it doesn't
mean that we'll or there may be ideas to
do this computers used to be the size of
entire rooms factories just to do simple
calculations and now you know we carried
around on our hip so
do you think lasers might not be
shrinkable in that way
uh they're also definitely materials
that can be made more efficient and it
can be drivers that are more efficient
so yes they will scale
um not sure though that they will scale
large enough to be a tabletop type of
device but then again I'd never I don't
want to say no because
again what do we see I mean like in the
development of the cell phone I mean
that was inconceivable 50 years ago
right to have something in your pocket
that tells you where to walk right and
how to drive I remember I my my first
GPS device was this large it was
handheld but it was huge and its only
job was to give me my coordinates as I
walked it was a fun sort of Novel and it
didn't work
no no yeah and now it's some chip inside
of something that one-tenth the size of
what the whole thing did and it does a
hundred other things including make a
phone call wow so so what's in the
future at your at your facility yeah
can we have guns that go
you want laser you want laser guns
yeah yeah
well there's actually a significant
effort on uh laser-based domain or
directed energy weapons I mean besides I
mean Fusion applications
uh that the in terms of the fusion
applications and work that will be done
in the National ignition facility you
want to achieve I mean significantly
higher gains I mean we this time we
obtained three Mega Joule I mean we
would like to obtain 10 mega Joule 50
Mega Joule 100 Mega joule and basically
improve I mean the process improve the
physics improve the quality of the
targets and investigate what needs to be
done and make it then the fusion yield I
mean uh useful I mean for our stockpile
stewardship goals so uh in the mission
statement of Lawrence Livermore lab if I
remember it correctly it's you are the
Nations
repository and intellectual Center for
everything
nuke right nuclear energy is you right
so uh if you once you're done doing the
fusion thing and then it gets mass
produced or whatever is there a next
project that's still within that mission
statement that you'll continue to do
well the next uh
challenge that we're looking at is even
higher yields
or yields around 500 megajoule or even a
giga joule which was always I mean the
goal of what we call the Laser
microfusion or the laboratory
microfusion facility
uh which would have significant
implications and significant benefits in
our goal of achieving the safety and
reliability of the stockpile and so that
would be I mean our next step in the in
the laboratory well of course I mean we
will be participating and helping out
and working together with Private
Industry developing inertial Fusion
Energy
wow okay so Chuck just so you're on the
same page as what he just said okay did
you hear him say gigajoules yes I did
okay so Joule is a unit of energy right
and one joule per second is by
definition a watt right so if he gets to
1.22 gigawatts
then you can travel through time no
that's it yeah yeah this game that is
the secret energy level in Back to the
Future that's amazing
um no this has been a delightful
conversation Bruno and uh we have not
met before thank you for uh taking our
call and if we can put you on speed dial
if you have any new new developments
we'll put you back on and we'll see uh
what else because our we have a very
eager curious and interested following
yes and our listeners are smart okay
all right no I'm I'm definitely
interested in uh in coming back because
there's a lot more to talk about we will
totally make that happen all right uh
again great to have you uh we our guest
has been Bruno van
[Music]
um
yes the national ignition facility at
the Lawrence Livermore National Labs and
uh he's in charge there what do you call
them Chuck Boss Man Boss Man
okay I get that all right put that on
your on your business card and then
people will treat you a whole other way
when you do that Chuck always good to
have you man always a pleasure Neil
deGrasse Tyson here this has been star
talk as always I bid you to keep looking
up
[Music]